Do you want to sit down?
Just look straight ahead.
That's really good. Great.
I like that.
I am an autistic person.
It is obvious when you see me.
I have no voice,
but yearn to say so much.
If you are willing to listen,
I will try to say how I feel.
(STATIC CRACKLING)
I live in a total blur
of information.
If I have too many people in a room
at one time and one place,
it is too overwhelming for me
to have to process.
I have to jiggle my brain
to make it settle.
It's just how I cope.
Water takes my pain away
because it allows me to lose myself
in a place that asks no questions
of my abilities.
Every drop lets me be me.
Before I could communicate
through typing,
I remember that I was frustrated
by people who were kind,
but didn't know my brain
was as good as people who can speak.
I remember being told that I liked
the Teletubbies, which I did,
but I wanted to move on and was
desperate to read books for my age.
Now I have the chance
to speak up for people like me.
I'm speaking from my heart.
Non-verbal people
are pleasing to be around
because we sense the world in
a deeper way than those who talk.
Because we cannot express
our emotions instantly,
we become deep thinkers.
People-watchers.
We have the same dreams
as everyone else,
so please don't treat us
differently.
Each of us is a star...
...eager to be discovered
and named in the atmosphere.
If you acknowledge our abilities,
we can shine brighter.
We have so much to say.
Please hear us.
(APPLAUSE)
I think we're all better people
for knowing Murray.
He's made such a big difference
to all our lives.
We can actually understand
how deeply he thinks about things.
We've been very privileged
to be part of his life.
His whole experience
is expressed there in just a few
minutes. It's...
It's wonderful. Wonderful.
That just sums up everything
about Murray, and it's just lovely
to be telling us how his world is.
MURRAY: I am happy
that the world
can see the real me.